GRADY POWELL: Brian,
Both of you guys are moving
forward into the next round.
In round three of
the competition,
we're going to be sending you
guys back to your home forges
to build an iconic
weapon from history.
That weapon is the
sword of Saladin.
This 12th century sword
belonged to Saladin,
a powerful Muslim leader
and the first sultan
of Egypt and Syria.
Believed to have been forged
from steel far superior
than any other
weapon of the time,
the sword is rumored to be
the sharpest in history.
Featuring a thin edged geometry,
the lightweight, curved blade
is designed to
effortlessly deliver
deep cuts and lethal chops.
With the help of
this deadly weapon,
Saladin founded a dynasty that
ruled much of the Middle East
for the 12th and 13th centuries.
The sword is a prominent feature
of a statue memorializing
Saladin that stands in front
of the ancient city of Damascus
in Syria.
WALTER: I'm absolutely excited.
And it's a lot longer than
what I normally build,
but yeah, we can do this.
GRADY POWELL: You
guys will only have
four days to
complete this weapon,
so we'll see when you get back.
Good luck.
We're back here,
[inaudible] liked the tool.
In good old
Springfield, New York,
I'm ready to get after it.
My biggest concern
is time management.
When you're on a timed
challenge like this,
every minute is precious.
Curve's going pretty well.
I'm done with my forging.
Head straight to the grinder and
start cleaning this thing up,
make it look right.
Time to quench.
That's the sound of
success right there.
BRIAN: Back at my home forge.
Making a sword with a bend in it
and such a steep arc like this
is worrying me a little bit.
I've not done a heat treat on
something of this shape before.
We're close.
I'm a little worried
about the heat treat.
And away we go.
Oh yeah.
That's it.
I got the curling on it.
I like it.
And I got the pommel built,
really much the shape I want.
This is a emerald-dyed
box elder burl.
I want it to look jeweled
without actually being jeweled.
We'll get everything
pretty well rough fit here.
I'm just kind of pecking
away at it, going slowly.
Nobody is going to
be able to complain
about that handle at all.
This has been a hell of a
ride, but I hope that can
bring me home the bacon.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
To find what kind of lethal
damage your weapons will do,
I will take your version
of Saladin's sword
and deliver some lethal
blows on this ram carcass.
Brian, you're up first.
You ready for this?
No, but I guess you
gotta do what you gotta do.
Absolutely.
Let's do it.
BRIAN: To see that
animal sitting
there with the horns hanging
out, it's nerve-wracking.
It's pretty hard on
a blade, so I'm not
sure what's going to happen.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Brian,
let's talk about your version
of Saladin's sword here.
I notice you have something
inscribed in there.
What is that?
BRIAN: That is
"Saladin" in Arabic.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Very
cool, very cool.
Now, your edge-- you
have a sharp edge.
This is a very
tough ram carcass.
On the neck chops,
it cut deeply.
And of course, on the body, it
cut through in three slices.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Walter,
your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
Let's make some ram chops.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right.
WALTER: Them bones in a
ram, those are no joke.
Their hides are as
tough as leather.
Their fur is abrasive
like sandpaper.
This is a legit test.
I'm slightly freaking out
on the inside right now.
[inaudible].
All right, Walter,
first up, your edge.
This is a wicked sharp grind.
[inaudible] sings
to me when they
just touch it and pull it out.
It is sharp.
Cutting through hair, a thick
spine, and into the meat.
Overall, sir, your
weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
DAVID BAKER: All
right, gentlemen,
you know what time it is.
It's time for the strength test.
Now, Saladin's army
in the 12th century
would have faced off against
men wearing chain mail, carrying
shields, and probably a helmet.
Now, to test your
blade's construction,
overall durability,
I'll be hacking
into our armored warriors here.
Brian, you're up.
Go ahead.
Wow.
Foof.
All right, Brian, blades
this sharp and with this kind
of edge geometry often take
a fairly substantial rolling
when they go up against armor--
yours really didn't.
I mean there's three
spots I can feel if I
run my fingernail along it.
Just a beautiful job.
Well done.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Walter, you're up.
Let's do it.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
Wow.
Nice.
All right, Walter,
there's a little bit
of a glinting and a
little bit of a rough spot
here, here, and maybe
here, but other than that,
this blade still has
a wicked edge on it.
Curvature is
really, really nice.
You nailed it, scale
right on, well done.
Thank you, sir.
DAVID BAKER: You bet.
(WHISPERING) Close race.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the sharpness test.
To find out how sharp
your weapons are,
I will take your
weapon and I will cut
through these Egyptian rugs.
Now, I'm looking for clean cuts.
Brian, you're up first.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Let's do this.
All right, Brian, let's
talk about your blade here.
It is razor sharp.
As I punctured and cut
through the carpet,
there were very clean cuts.
Overall, sir, your
edge, it will cut.
Thank you.
All right, Walter, you ready?
Absolutely.
Let's do this.
[ringing sound]
Listen to that ring.
All right, Walter, let's
talk about your weapon here--
razor sharp.
It was easy to penetrate,
very easy to drag across.
These are very clean cuts.
Overall, sir, your
weapon, it will cut.
Thank you, sir.
GRADY POWELL: All right,
gentlemen, the judges
have made the decision.
Today's champion is Walter.
What, what?
I'm just in shock.
[laughs] I can't believe this.
GRADY POWELL: Now,
unfortunately, Brian, that
means you did not win today.
DAVID BAKER: This is
the closest decision
I have ever had to make, ever.
Brian, you brought us an
absolutely beautiful weapon.
It tested fantastically.
It felt fantastic in my hand.
We made this decision based
on the smallest of details,
and it came down to the
curvature of the blade.
Yours just has a little wobble
in it, the other doesn't--
it's that close.
You should be incredibly
proud of that blade,
and it was an absolute pleasure
to be able to wield it.
Thank you very much.
Brian, unfortunately
that means
you didn't make the cut today.
And I'm going to have to ask
you to head off the forge floor.
Bro, it's been an honor.
I'm a little disappointed to
not be in the winner's circle,
but very proud of
the fact that Dave
said it was one of
the hardest decisions
they've ever had to make.
I feel I did pretty good.
GRADY POWELL: Well, Walter,
congratulations, buddy.
You are the Forge of Fire champ,
and you'll be going out of here
with a check for $10,000.
How do you feel?
I don't even know right now.
I won.
I can't believe it.
$10,000 is nothing
to sneeze at, but I
want to take a portion of it
and donate it to some kind
of cancer organization.
Cancer has taken a lot of
people away from me that
I care about-- it took my dad--
and I want to be able to
give back a little bit.
What a wild ride.
[music playing]